what is the biggest question that you're
excited for fans to get answers to
without flipping away the answer oh gosh
the biggest question is probably is
probably what's gonna happen to chloe
Lucifer Lucifer Lucifer well we think
it's gonna be a wedding
only eg has the Lucifer season 5 romance
updates that you've been waiting for
people are very invested in Lucifer and
Chloe's relationship what kind of
journey do they go on in this final
season I mean a continuation of the
Bunker's journey they've already been on
a Lucifer that's what we call them
Lucifer Lucifer well why didn't you say
so in the first place
I love that we opened with I'm upset I'm
heartbroken that I get to play that that
he's always kind of the one not in
denial of any times that I'm hurting but
I you know he tries to make me feel
better but it's scared to go there he's
not the best communicator right you know
and things come to him easily and things
do not come to Chloe easily so it's
always with Tom or I should say Chloe in
there it's always fun to play because it
feels very balanced and like where I
might be good at one thing he's not and
vice-versa so we still have that but I
actually am interested to see where we
go this season because I know there's a
lot of surprises in store set a promise
we start the season with Lucifer in Hell
what and Chloe on earth after they
exchanged after she's finally told him I
love you I love you my first love was
never Eve was she who Chloe some viewers
will note that Lucifer didn't actually
say I love you back was that intentional
everything's intentional Alicia
do we get a full I love you in this
season I can neither confirm nor deny
now obviously it's at the core and the
heartbeat of the Lucifer story this
season but the Chloe still got a few
things that she needs to learn about you
know what she's all about and certain
things come to light this season for
Chloe that she's still got things to
find out where do things pick back up in
season five is there a time jump yeah
yeah
so season four ends with Chloe you know
she knows everything now and she tells
the super that she's in love with him
and wants to be with him and he flies
off a balcony yeah oh harsh so rude I
know I don't tough crowd so then yeah
season five picks up lip see so Chloe's
heartbroken but she's sort of trying to
I must play it cool more or less with
maze they're going out there drinking a
lot they're dancing but they're also
mazes helping her as a bounty hunter at
the LAPD so season five picks up Chloe
has no idea where Lucifer is she's
heartbroken but trying not to show it
she doesn't know that he went back to
hell she knows he left but it she
doesn't think he's ever coming back but
she's not sure okay so I don't know
maybe like if your partner's like we're
breaking up and I'm leaving yes but no
word of when he might come back or
what's going on in there just
instantaneously gone
[Music]
at what point this season do we find out
how he gets back if he gets back from
hell to earth you find out a lot of
stuff in the first episode actually
about what Lucifer's intentions are that
ever get answered yeah it gets answered
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm not it doesn't
take too long I don't think you were
right about the prophecy we did get it
wrong
how does the prophecy play into this
final season um the prophecy at the
moment it's not so tiring in
particularly with this season but
obviously the threat is still there that
Lucifer had to go back to Hell to to
rule it because the demons were uprising
so you know if Lucifer's not there and
he's gonna be back here always gonna be
there what's gonna happen it's never
safe yes it's going to be so much fun
you recently got married okay is Lucifer
ready for marriage marriage the eternal
bachelor well if it's the right person
like it has been in my actual life but
ya know the devil get married in the
presence of God
well sing done enough know if there's a
wedding a close-up her wedding oh I do
not know if there's a wedding with that
hmm I'm thinking like you know the
wedding scene in beetlejuice yes
which actually was my last year's
Halloween costume with my dog my dog was
beetlejuice I was indeed yes yes yes
there we go with the spiky bangs Winona
Ryder yeah I don't know if there's a
wedding but oh my god I wonder where the
wedding would be if there was was he
come down the aisle to marry I'm gonna
ask you that question who would she come
down to this should wear black I think
she wear a white gown okay yeah they
probably wear something along the lines
of this yeah I would imagine a classic
tax don't know what you come down to
walking on sunshine between under waves
[Music]
really what would you say so oddly like
depressingly a beat like like with the
bouquet and walk and I'm that might make
me cry like immediate divorce uh well
what would I say I'd say black dress
tons of fire oh yeah
like definitely inhale a black dress and
I don't know maybe like um like a very
heavy classical piece like maybe vogner
Wow you know some like awful like um
really like what do you call it acid
metal have you not heavy metal like
death metal how seriously would you sing
she would say yes if you were to propose
oh my god are you kidding no matter what
she pretends she doesn't want immediate
yes yeah immediate yeah she's madly in
love with him
yeah yeah I mean Khloe is just madly in
love with Lucifer I have what about a
baby another angel baby
Comanche slash demon baby yeah Damian
[Laughter]
yeah all of these things could happen
well there Lucifer did say to a melody
well it's really surprising that he
hasn't got someone pregnant at this
moment exactly that's why I think the
foreshadowings been there yeah who knows
the father blesses it then then maybe
maybe you're right I need to have a
child I said it would be an angel he
said it would be half angel half demon
yeah I'm going full lizard scales two
horns pitchfork tail yeah yeah okay
alright maybe with like an LAPD badge
you're thinking about um yeah
is there a happy ending to this story I
think there is a happy ending I think my
favorite stories have always been
stories that have from the message at
the end is hope and so I think that
we're pushing somewhere towards down
this best of luck with you crazy kids
alright okay so there's gonna be a happy
ending but our favorite devil still has
a few issues to work out with amenadiel
dr. Linda
and baby Charlie do we see Charlie is he
an infant all throughout season five I
think I'm allowed to say this we pick up
six months later a little bit at a time
yeah yeah so so he's still you know he's
still a baby
how was Lucifer involved in the baby's
life this season that's a little tricky
I can't really talk about that but he's
been a little bit of let's just say he's
been a little bit of an absent uncle for
his own reasons for his own yeah for his
own reasons which is funny because I
asked him I said is there a chance that
Lucifer has a baby with Chloe what do
you think cousins I think that would be
great I don't know if that's gonna
happen but I would love to see Lucifer
as a father that's just that's DB's
thing I would love to see Lucifer as a
dad that'll be great
I think so too so do you think he's
ready to settle down not yet but it's my
hope that he will be that he gets there
that's that's Michael yeah do you know
how this season ends I do know how the
how the season ends how do you feel
about the ending I think the ending is
fantastic yeah I think it's fantastic I
think it's a gonna surprise a lot of
people I don't think it's gonna be the
ending that everyone necessarily assumes
it could be but I don't think it's gonna
be the type of ending where people are
disappointed I think people are really
gonna be surprised and it's gonna be the
perfect type of ending for you said it's
not what people assume what do you think
people assume it's gonna be I think most
people would like to see Lucifer and
Chloe on earth growing old together
living happily ever after
so it's not that
could be could not be I don't think it
is
so we'll see would you call it a happy
ending like a happily ever after
even though it's not that I would say
that it's happy-ish of course where do
you think I'm gonna deal and lucifer's
relationship is that as we progress this
season they've also had sort of a rocky
they did they did they started out
really rough we've seen them kind of
find themselves and find their
relationship and it's kind of grown to a
place where it's really special I think
it will continue in that vein at this
point in the season we haven't gotten
there yet
but I have a feeling it's going to end
on a very high note but last season
Lucifer says I'm killed isn't that
wonderful
he doesn't mean therapy anymore yeah is
there more therapy to be had with
between him and dr. Linda there's a lot
more therapy okay he's not done he's not
healed now he has issues there there
will be a lot more yeah yeah what do we
dive into like what kind of issues I
would probably say there will be some
issues surrounding forgiveness and maybe
acknowledging that he's made some
mistakes okay that's what I'd say yeah
don't you see this is progress when we
left off Lucifer of course goes back to
hell is amenadiel at all helpful in
bringing him back to earth I would say
he's helpful and that's all I can say
okay but I would say that he's he's
helpful and I think he's also somewhat
nervous because you know he did start
the run of the show off saying that
that's where he needed to be and there's
a reason why you know I would just like
to say that amenadiel keeps being proven
rights
it may not always feel good and people
don't like to the guy that's always
right yeah but he's a lot of times was
the reason if you will yes but I but I
do think he's gonna help Lucifer finds
his happiness and find his find his
destiny Louis
[Music]